hey francis do you want to keep your
online activity
private yes i don't want anyone to know
i secretly watch
bbc comedy embarrassing that's why you
need surf shark vpn
how can shark surf shut up surf shark is
a virtual private network
available as an easy to use app and
browser extension that lets you place
your laptop or phone
anywhere in the world allowing you to
access the internet as if you were in
another country
this means i can access a whole host of
websites
that i wouldn't be able to access in the
uk not only that you can protect your
online identity by masking your true ip
address
with surfshark you can protect yourself
from data theft
tracking surveillance and commercial
targeting and it's
great value for money because one
surfshark account can be used on
multiple devices
so you can access problematic content
wherever you are and by problematic
content we do mean trigonometry click
the link below
and use our code trigonometry to get
83 percent off plus three extra months
for free
surf shark also offers a 30 day money
back guarantee
so there's no risk to trying it out for
yourself click the link below
and use our code trigonometry to get
83 off plus three extra months for free
before we begin we'd like to say that in
our opinion it is not suitable
for children or for those of you who may
have a nervous disposition
[Music]
hello and welcome to a very special
live episode of trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kitten and this is a
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
doesn't get any more fascinating than
the returning guest for you today
he's an evolutionary biologist who's
been covering the lab leak hypothesis
and a lot more please uh welcome it's
brett weinstein
brett welcome back to the show gentlemen
thanks for having me on
it's a pleasure to have you on before we
get started uh francis and i have
something to say to the guards of
youtube
uh we here at trigonometry believe that
anyone has any wrong thoughts about
anything to do with covert is
inherently evil we will not be talking
about anything we're not
allowed to by youtube because obviously
they should decide what everyone thinks
and what anyone says
that's how we approach it censorship is
brilliant uh we also love xi jinping
he's a great guy as well
so and the w the world health
organization are wonderful we're totally
on board with all their restrictions as
well
um and yeah we definitely won't be
having any problematic conversations
please don't cancel us exactly and once
we've got that out of the way and uh
that was all humor of course but but the
one thing we do know is you have been
covering
uh some uh potential alternative
treatments for kovid
and you've had things taken down from
your channel uh for doing so
uh so we i think it's best that we stay
away from that and if people want to
talk about that or listen to things
about that they can go and check it out
uh on your channel uh on other platforms
which
uh that we know how to find but we
better they better hurry
because yeah uh as of yesterday youtube
has moved even farther in the direction
of hurling
dark horse off the platform uh we had
another
video taken down a strike against our
clips channel
so it looks like um youtube is about
sick of open discussion and anyway
it's uh it's a good moment to get
yourself up to speed before there's no
place left to do that
well absolutely bro and the
conversations you have been having
are very very interesting i do recommend
people check them out and make up their
own mind
obviously we're not endorsing any
particular view because we're not
medical experts and
you know people can go and check it out
for themselves that's what we always
recommend
but listen we wanted to talk to you
about uh the censorship which you're
experiencing
uh but before we do that i do think it's
helpful to first of all
having a conversation about the lac lab
league situation about the oranges have
covered and the reason i say this
is not only because that in and of
itself matters but it's a
crucial example of what happens when
social media companies are big tech
companies are deciding what
can and can't be talked about and then
later suddenly find that
actually that should have been talked
about a year ago so can we
first of all before we get into lab leak
and the idea that covert may have come
from a lab
why does it matter where covet came from
brett
well there are really two general
reasons one of them is widely
uh agreed by people who've thought about
the issue and the other one i seem to be
one of the lone
voices maybe the only voice making this
point but um the first reason
is because if this came from a lab and
it was indeed
a leak then it is the result
of predictable error and that is to say
that in choosing to do this work and in
fact what we now understand
in choosing to circumvent the ban on
this work
by offshoring it to china we effectively
put the world
in jeopardy of a very serious
pandemic and the fact is even if this
somehow did come from nature which is
still a possibility though
the likelihood of it grows smaller with
each week
but even if this did come from nature
the fact is the work in question was
taking place
and it does place the world in danger of
a pandemic
because laboratory leaks are not rare in
fact they happen all the time
so the first reason that matters is
because
if covet 19 is the result of a lab leak
then
we can potentially correct our behavior
going forward
and eliminate that hazard if we pretend
that there's no chance it came from the
laboratory then we will
presumably not only continue that work
but covet 19 will be used as a
demonstration that that work needs to be
at a much larger scale because it was
not fast enough
uh to prevent this pandemic so it
matters a great deal i would say because
it what we do downstream of it would be
potentially the opposite
of what we would do if this was a
natural spillover event and how does it
reflect on the chinese bre and
particularly the
i say the chinese but really the ccp if
it's found out that
that it was a leak from a laboratory
that started the
virus well i think frankly this is a
little bit
of uh a dead end in terms of the
analysis
because at some level the sense that
this took place in china
in a chinese lab and that the leak may
have emerged from there by this i mean
the research that might have led to such
a pathogen
and the possible leak looks most likely
to have come from the wuhan lab because
of course wuhan is the
the origin point of the pandemic on the
other hand
the work in question was clearly the
result
of a quadrant of the international
scientific community
deciding that this work needed to be
done and
innovating the techniques with which to
do it
and so certainly the chinese have a
tremendous and by the chinese i don't
really mean the chinese i mean
the chinese government the chinese
government bears a tremendous amount
of responsibility for its lack of
candor and for what to all appearances
is a massive cover-up um
you know that is the responsibility of
the chinese government on the other hand
the work in question
is a much bigger failure than that right
it certainly
appears to involve uh tony fauci
it involves eco health alliance whatever
that
is whether that is actually a research
organization
or a laundering operation that allows
money
uh to circumvent a u.s ban on gain of
function research
i don't think it's entirely clear but
what is clear
is that there is a small cabal of people
who have been
pushing this work forward over the
objection of scientific colleagues who
were clearly right to attempt to raise
the
alarm and to to generate a ban on gain
of function research
so i i think it is a mistake to focus on
china because
the failure is much bigger than that and
the implications are
uh much more profound all right well
let's not focus on china then i think
you make a good point i think let's
focus on on the science of this and
yeah can we go back though i realize i
failed to fully answer your question
which actually probably uh
goes to where you're headed next you
said let's stick to the science the
place in which i believe
there is a lot to be gained from knowing
where uh
soros kovi 2 came from that i seem to be
alone on
is the belief that were we to understand
let's say that this was a lab leak which
seems highly probable
if this was a lab leak what are the
protocols that were used to take the
ancestor virus from nature
which by all appearances would not have
been
highly infectious of humans and almost
certainly would not have been
transmissible between humans
what are the protocols of the
experiments that produced a highly
infectious agent in humans like sars
kobe 2.
if we were to find out for example that
ferrets were used
in this process we would understand a
lot about why the virus behaves the way
that it does
right ferrets are used in laboratory
environment because they have
an ace2 receptor that looks very much
like the human one so if you were trying
to produce
a a coronavirus that was infectious in
humans you might
serially passage the virus through
ferrets if that happened
then we know then we would know that
ferrets are an organism in which we
could study the progress of this disease
and understand a great deal more about
it because the disease is not normal
the the number of tissues that it
impacts is is incredible
the number of symptoms and so in essence
my point more broadly than ferrets is
knowing the protocols that generated the
virus if it was generated in the
laboratory
potentially gives us a tremendous leg up
on fighting covet
it would allow us to narrow our search
in understanding what the virus is and
understanding what its vulnerabilities
might be
predicting what it might do both
epidemiologically and evolutionarily
going forward
and so my sense is at the very least we
have the right to that information
in order to see whether or not there are
useful tools buried within it
and by playing this game where we
pretend that the majority of the
evidence still points toward a natural
origin which is absolutely false
by playing that game what we are
effectively doing is running out the
clock when in fact
time is of the essence that makes
perfect sense brett so let's get into
the
into the science of it from the
beginning because there will be a lot of
people who are tuning into this
who have absolutely no idea what you're
talking about and i'll be honest with
you to some extent
both francis and i are two of those
people right what are you talking about
i understand everything mate
the day you start doing biology mates
that they were all screwed but look
uh right seriously though from the very
beginning
just take us through at a sort of normal
person's level of understanding
what what are you talking about what do
you mean lab leak what what
what do you mean it was made in a lab
like what on earth are you talking about
so first of all um there's been a game
played
right it is implausible that human
beings could have designed a virus like
this that is true
and so by pretending that lab leak is
synonymous with a designed
virus there were for many months
uh a sort of false sense that people
were alleging something
you know at the remote end of science
fiction when in fact those of us
who were pointing out that the evidence
did in fact point towards
a laboratory leak we're not making that
claim at all
our point was there are things that we
accomplish in the lab
that we cannot say how they will look uh
in advance what we do is we use
evolution we harness evolution
in the laboratory to design things that
we would not know
beforehand we're going to work so for
example
the spike protein of sars cov2
is spectacularly well designed to infect
human tissue but if you took the sort of
state-of-the-art knowledge before
sars cov2 was known in the world
we would not have predicted if you
showed somebody the sequence that it
would have been a highly effective
pathogen so we
learned that from sars kovi 2. and the
question is
did scientists train an ancestral virus
to infect humans in the laboratory
by effectively forcing it to jump from
one creature to the next possibly
ferrets
possibly humanized mice or possibly
the cells of human airway all of these
things are
laboratory platforms that can be used to
teach a virus evolutionarily how to
accomplish
jumping from one cell to the next or one
individual to the next
and so the question is we know that
these um
experiments were being done they were
being done primarily
in north carolina in the ralph baric lab
and in wuhan
in the xi jiang li lab those two labs
are connected they
are uh effectively ralph barrick uh
trained english in these techniques um
and these are the two primary places in
the world where this work is done
so when the virus emerged in wuhan
it immediately raised red flags for some
of us now in my case i didn't know that
there was a bsl4
lab in wuhan and when i first looked
the story is this heather and i were in
the amazon working on
the first draft of our upcoming book
and so we were completely out of contact
with the world i mean literally
no contact for a couple weeks and when
we came out
we were in ecuador and we emerged from
the amazon and we're on the river at the
first place where
one's phone can pick up just wisps of
signal and
um there was a story that's stuck out
from all the rest the story was
that the first case of what was then
called novel coronavirus
was in ecuador already and we didn't
we'd never heard of this and so i
started to look into it
and initially i thought and i had
as a graduate student i studied bats and
so i looked at the story that was
being distributed and it said that a
virus appears to have jumped from
horseshoe bats probably through the
bush meat trade at the wuhan seafood
market
and is now spreading in a concerning way
even outside of china and i looked at
that and
i looked at the papers in question and
it all made sense to me
and then i tweeted that it did i i
explained that uh
i had been a bat biologist and that the
story made sense and that the bush meat
trade is indeed incredibly dangerous
it's probably the source of
hiv for example and that it should be
shut down
and i immediately got pushback from some
of my followers
who said so you think it's a coincidence
that there's a bsl4 lab studying these
viruses in wuhan
and i thought what the hell
that's an amazing coincidence and then i
thought well maybe there are a lot more
of these labs than i think
no there aren't there are only a few
labs studying these viruses and one of
them happens to be in wuhan and then
i looked into the distribution of the
bats they're not in wuhan
and so it was this curiouser and
curiouser phenomenon the deeper you dug
the more it looked anomalous that this
virus had emerged
in wuhan at the location where such
viruses were
under manipulation alright so
that of course uh was a message that
some of us
tried to put into the world that there
was a question to be answered is this a
simple coincidence and if so how do we
reconcile it and the more you look for a
way to reconcile it the less sense it
makes
and then yuri dagan did the first deep
investigation
into the genomics of sars kovi ii
and in fact yuri
much like many of us who ended up
pushing the lab leak hypothesis into the
public view
yuri was essentially trying to reassure
himself
that this was not a laboratory leak and
that those people who were saying it was
were
uh you know off the deep end and the
deeper he dug the more he found that
actually the genome
sure looks like it might have been the
product of
uh laboratory experiments and we now
know from
uh tony fauci's emails that a lot of the
experts in the field when they first
looked at the genome that was their
first thought too including christian
anderson who has been one of the lead
proponents of the idea
that uh lab leak is pure conspiracy
theory and that those who are
advancing it are out of their depth and
that the genome
uh could only have come from nature he
turns out privately to have thought that
the genome that he was looking at was
completely inconsistent with
evolutionary theory
so anyway there are
multiple different kinds of evidence
that point towards the lab
it is not a completely
closed case in other words there are
things that we could see that would
alert us that a story had unfolded that
we didn't know anything about
that would explain how it got from
nature to people
but the likelihood at this point is very
very low that it came from nature
and does that mean that the virus is
more dangerous because it leaks from
because it leaked from a lab because
in my head as a layman i think have they
genetically altered this virus does it
make it more deadly etc etc
do we know the long-term effects of it
um those are good questions let me try
to put it in context
most so there are innumerable viruses
in nature that could in principle
infect humans the problem is in order
for a virus to become
pandemic in humans it has to learn to
tricks a virus that jumps from a bat to
a person for example
needs to move from cell to cell in order
to be able to create enough
offspring viruses to be viable in the
world
and those offspring viruses need to be
produced in a way that causes them to be
passed on
right so it has to learn to infect a
person and it has to learn
to spread between people both of those
are evolutionarily
very difficult jobs it's not that it
doesn't happen
but the point is the likelihood of it
happening if you were to
contact an animal in the wild and it was
sick with a virus and that virus managed
to get into your airway
the chances of it infecting a cell
successfully
and then infecting neighboring cells
enough that there was a substantial
population of viruses
and then those viruses being capable of
infecting someone else
are almost zero so again it can happen
but it requires some very rare things
to to all go the same direction
so what we know in this case is that
this virus is spectacularly well adapted
to humans and actually very poorly
adapted to bats
right so it has done a lot of learning
somewhere
and the thing that is most conspicuous
about the evidence
is that there is no hint that this virus
learned to do what it does in the human
population
at the point we first know about it in
wuhan it is already a spectacularly
capable virus
so can i interrupt you there just again
from a layman's point of view
is it possible for a virus to be uh
a crappy virus and bats and a hugely
effective virus in humans just by
chance or accident or whatever you might
describe it
well it depends what you mean at a
technical level
first of all the virus has if if we're
right about what the ancestor is and i
have never heard anyone
challenge that right the ancestor
appears to have been a virus of
horseshoe bats and there's a small
uh subfamily of bats that essentially
specializes there's a diversity of these
these viruses um
those viruses have to be good at
infecting bats in order
to stick around from one year to the
next
so we know that the ancestor was good at
infecting bats and we know that cyrus
cov2 is good at infecting
humans and we have zero explanation for
how it got from a to b
uh other than the possibility of the lab
or
there's some natural population of some
creature that we have yet to find in
which it circulated for a while
or there's some population of humans
that had a an epidemic
that so far has not been uh connected
the dots have not been connected in
spite of a huge amount of
search effort so what about the pangolin
we keep being told about the pangolin
the pangolin was nonsense um these
viruses do not
inhabit pangolins it is inconsistent
with the data in fact everybody now
admits that the pangolin was a dead end
and i think
frankly dead end isn't even the right
description it looks like it was a cover
story
right it doesn't make sense ecologically
it doesn't make sense genomically it
does not fit with the affinities of the
viruses in question so
that was a dead end there could be
probably more likely it would be
a carnivoron um you know
so a relative of of uh
things like weasels which in fact would
explain
you know there's one of two explanations
for why this virus which
does occasionally spread to other
creatures but does not spread between
members of those other species
with two exceptions ferrets and minx
right so those ferrets and minks are
very closely related they're both
weasels
so there's a question about why this
virus seems to be good in people and
weasels
um but in any case the most people are
like weasels
sorry i have to say that no you did i
know yeah
so let me try to remember oh the
question that you asked
uh francis was is it possible
for the virus to just simply have
accidentally been good at infecting
humans and
the point is is it possible to take a
bucket
of mechanical parts throw them out the
window and have them assemble
into a robot and the answer is
a philosopher could make a technical
argument that it is possible
right but it is not a meaningful
probability their likelihood is so very
low now this might be slightly higher
than that
but what you would what you would get in
every case that we've seen
is a virus that had maybe unusually good
ability to jump between species it would
initially have a very poor ability
to jump between individuals of the new
species but it would have enough
that selection could fix it right that's
what you would expect in a natural
spillover event
but that period in which natural
selection
fixed the virus and made it very good at
jumping between individuals of a species
that it did not initially inhabit
that would leave a signature that
signature would be in the world
and we would find it and we have no
evidence of it what we have
is a virus that was so incredibly well
adapted at the point it first shows up
in humans
that it does very little of all it just
simply takes off across the globe that's
a
very anomalous fact right it could be
explained
by a natural spillover event and a
mystery population of either people or
some other creature somewhere but
we have not found them there's no hint
of them that's why the wukon lab
looks to be such a likely explanation
and you say it's a likely explanation
but
to me this sounds like something out of
the realms of science fiction
you know a manipulated virus is leaked
out into the world creates a pandemic
if it's as you say has been manipulated
and
you know created in a lab as it were
i'm using layman's language and i
realized these might be technically
incoherent etc etc but does that mean
that it's somehow
it could be more deadly it could be more
it's far more infectious
we don't know what the long time
implications of this virus are
surely that's terrifying isn't it
absolutely terrifying and this is part
of the problem
is that the re let's assume that
everybody is
on the up and up with respect to why
they were working on
these viruses okay i think we had a
group of scientists who really were
terrified
that a spillover event was going to
cause a tremendous human pandemic that
would be devastating
and they were racing against the clock
to prevent it right i think they were
wrong
about how likely that is to happen from
nature and we can talk about why
but let's imagine that that was just
simply what they were thinking
and let's imagine that maybe they took
humanized mice
ferrets airway tissue and they passaged
a virus through these things in order to
enhance its infectivity of humans
part of the problem is they are making a
puzzle for the virus to evolutionarily
solve that is not exactly like
nature right so imagine for a second
that this
virus you know got into a
wild population of weasels well in order
to spread from one weasel to the next
it has to leave those weasels healthy
enough to
go about and encounter each other right
it's not going to get very far if it
infects
a weasel and knocks it flat and no other
weasel will come near it because it
looks sickly
and even if it infects other weasels in
its burrow if it doesn't get to the next
burrow it's going extinct so
a virus typically has to leave a
creature healthy enough to spread it
now there are some diseases that don't
work like this right so for example
dengue yellow fever malaria which are
spread by a mosquito
they can knock you flat and in fact it
might be a good thing to knock you flat
because if you're knocked flat and you
can't even swat a mosquito away you
might be more likely to transmit them
but for something like a coronavirus it
does not want to debilitate its host
because debilitating its host reduces
the chances it will spread
that's very different if you've got a
cage full of ferrets
right a cage full of ferrets that can't
get away from each other
right so one of the things that i think
is likely to have happened here
is that we made a much worse virus from
the point of view
of the damage it does to the body
because the damage that it did in the
lab if that's where it came from
wasn't critical in the story of how it
spread from one creature to the next
right so i do think the chances are
i have regarded covet 19 as a
very dangerous disease from the
beginning and many people i think have
been misled by the low
case fatality rate right it's not an
especially fatal disease
but it is an extremely destructive
disease and an extremely transmissible
disease
and my feeling from very early on
was we have a limited amount of time
to drive this virus extinct and that if
we don't
it's going to become a permanent fellow
traveler of humans and that will be
a an unmeasurable tragedy
which i think we still don't know uh
whether we're stuck with it but because
of the way we've mishandled
the treatment and prevention of covid
it's a strong possibility that we won't
be able to rid ourselves of it
so what you're talking about essentially
is every every winter we have like with
the flu we have a wave of
of this virus but unlike flu it leaves
lasting damage in many of the people
that it infects
well i also think we underrate the
seriousness of flu and i've been
bothered for many years by the fact that
i think we have a model in our heads
that if you get better from a disease
that you got away with it right it may
have robbed you of a couple weeks but
you know whatever that's that's the cost
and what we don't realize
is that these things all have costs they
destroy tissue
and you know they rob you of future life
and they cause you to age faster
um so anyway i regard the flu as serious
but this is much more serious some of
the kinds of damage the number of
tissues
involved um is particularly troubling
and yes it could become uh
permanent it could you know it will
probably have some seasonality to it
on the basis that our behavior is so
seasonal
uh that you know it will likely even if
it didn't have any seasonality
built into it the simple fact that we
are outdoors more
when it's warm in the you know the
temperate zones
and that it doesn't seem to transmit
outdoors will give it a seasonal
signature but yeah it could become
a permanent a permanent pathogen of
people and that will be a spectacular
tragedy
all the greater if it has come from a
laboratory and is a self-inflicted wound
brett let me try and summarize
uh very quickly some of the things
you've said and do correct me at any
point if i
if i've got it wrong and before i do it
uh my producer just reminded us that
we've got a lot of questions flowing
already uh there's some links in the
bottom for paypal and super chats which
you're free to use
send in questions there will be that one
thing that shall not be named that we
won't be asking
about uh but apart from that uh
so that of course is voldemort voldemort
exactly
uh we can't we can't talk about it uh in
euphemistic terms
apparently not uh but uh we we
actually we want to talk about the
censorship of it a little bit later on
but but just sticking to to the virus
for now sure
you're saying there was the initial idea
was like it's a bio weapon you're saying
it's not it was not designed uh for
that sort of purpose well if it was
designed so let me point us to
yesterday's new york times
so the new york times has been uh
screwing the pooch on this story from
the beginning there are occasional
glimmers of hope like
brett stevens recent column but uh
yesterday the new york times ran
an extraordinary uh
piece on an interview with xi jiang li
where the reporter almost preposterously
claims she just phoned up
gee and the phone was answered and
uh anyway it's a remarkable piece and it
doesn't really hold together as
plausible but it does
participate in this very broad scale
attempt
to regain control of the narrative
uh in the aftermath of uh
of nicholas wade's piece which
seemed to cause the world to wake up to
what was going on in the lab league
story
but the piece basically
says that xi jiang li is very upset
that the world is uh looking at her with
suspicion
and that she can't produce the evidence
because there is no evidence of
something that didn't happen which is
something she has been saying for a long
time but of course
she is a citizen of china the
interview is mostly over email
so there's a question about what this
even is other than just a sort of formal
statement yes this didn't come from the
wuhan lab which we've heard many many
many times
and does not square with the evidence
but here's here's the point i want to
make
the new york times has not put together
that
their attempt to resurrect the idea that
this did not come from the wuhan lab
leads you to an even worse possibility
which has to remain on the table
right but the evidence that this came
from
a lab is substantial and it comes in
numerous different forms
that does not go away if it didn't come
from the wuhan lab let's say that the
wuhan lab
threw open its doors let us look in its
freezers let us look at its lab
notebooks let's say that they've
preserved the evidence instead of
disappearing it we looked at all that
and there was really no evidence that
this had happened in the wuhan lab then
the question is okay then what lab did
it happen
right because the next most likely
hypothesis and
i want your listeners to understand this
i am not saying that i think this
happened
i am saying there is no evidence for
this but if we discover
that the wuhan lab is in fact innocent
and the virus
still appears to have been the product
of laboratory activity
then the question is who released it in
wuhan
and why and the obvious answer would be
so that people would assume it came from
the wuhan lab
right i don't think this happened
there's no evidence for it but if the
new york times and others
are so sure that xi jing li is innocent
because she says she is
and we can get an investigation that can
establish that in one way or another
the next most likely thing becomes it
was some other lab and wuhan
was the cover story brad the reason i'm
asking is if i temporarily put my
tinfoil hat on and take a puff on my
imaginary
uh spliff here is
i mean it's a virus that's killing
primarily old people in a world that
feels very overpopulated to a lot of
people
well it's not deadly enough to you know
certainly one can imagine i mean
one can imagine that some diabolical
force might have decided that it wanted
fewer people on planet earth
but this is not a especially good virus
from that perspective it doesn't kill
enough people and the people it kills
are more often towards the end of their
their lives so it doesn't look like an
effective weapon
in and of itself now if you put on the
tinfoil hat
and pass this belief very thanks very
much
it you know could be useful as a
disruptive agent
or it could be useful if others
did not have a remedy for it but you
knew of one
right there are ways in which it could
be used as a weapon but in and of itself
it does not look especially weapon-like
fair enough so it wasn't uh you you're
saying there's a possibility but you
don't believe that that's what happened
so it was it was a failed experiment or
a leak
an experiment was happening and somehow
it probably got out of that lab into
the wild so to speak is that is that a
correct summation of your
point of view yeah so back in
i guess it would have been may
of 2020 i put together a flow chart of
all of the real possibilities for where
this thing came from the various natural
stories that came directly from bats it
came through an intermediate species
it came through the lab as a result of
weapons research it came through the lab
as the
result of pandemic prevention research
all of the things were on the table and
i went through
and i gave probabilities for each of
these things based on whether there was
any evidence for them based on how many
uh different uh facts that are not in
evidence would have to be true in order
for it to be right
and basically the point is you can't
knock
the idea of it came from some other lab
and was released in wuhan so that wuhan
would be blamed for it you can't knock
that off completely because the whole
point
of such a thing would be to leave a
false impression on the other hand
the thing that really sticks out to me
is
the appearance of a massive cover-up
of what was going on in the wuhan
lab which would not have occurred if the
wuhan lab was innocent in other words
why go around and behave like a very
guilty lab
if you are in fact an innocent lab
because the the whole key at that point
would be look
you know i know how this looks it didn't
come from here
here's how we know and um we're
on board with figuring out where it did
come from right
that would have been the right approach
and of course there are things about the
the government of china that might be
inconsistent with that kind of openness
but nonetheless
if they are an innocent lab they have
behaved in exactly the opposite way
including
renaming samples in a way that is
against scientific protocol
deleting databases that might have
contained exculpatory
evidence the whole thing looks
like the behavior of guilty people
who know what happened and wish to
evade blame so i think you know
could it be that this was dual purpose
research inside the wuhan lab
that it was partly about weapons and it
was partly about pandemics
that's possible we don't know there are
slight hints of such a thing but i think
even if this was
partially weapons research the release
was still accidental
that's the most likely thing and the
most likely lab for it to have been
released from
was the lab in wuhan bret
there's a question that i really want to
ask and it's a
it's a tim 4 hat question in a way but
it just feels more and more
how can i put this pertinent as we go on
i see
governments becoming ever more stringent
with lockdown particularly in the uk
yet at the same time we get we get told
that you know it's
it's a virus that is you know not
particularly dangerous dangerous to
young people it's dangerous to old
people
it feels at times that we're not being
told the truth about this virus
and the impact it's having on the body
uh
is that tim foil hat question or am i
asking something particularly valid
well first of all i
i don't know how we all should be
dealing
with the question of tin foil hat
questions
right at some level we've been
frightened
off of talking about collusion
even though every human being should be
aware that collusion is a very
common feature of civilization that
doesn't you know most
hypotheses of collusion are definitely
going to be false
however there's an awful lot of
collusion in the world
and the the idea that we should be timid
at
all about asking the question about
collusion when there is
anomalous behavior and obvious lying
uh we shouldn't be embarrassed about it
at all and in fact the right tools to
use
when collusion is to question are
scientific tools so
what i would say is there's a reason and
i i was
nearly alone in this there's a reason
that i was
quite inflexible about the idea that the
only right way to refer to this was the
lab leak hypothesis and that the word
theory was
in and of itself a problem because you
know if you think about evolutionary
theory we call evolutionary
theory because it is the presumed right
answer
based on a tremendous amount of work
right so to call this a lab leak theory
is an error to call it a hypothesis
tells you exactly what the rules of
engagement are
what the legitimate tools are what the
standards of evidence are
and so my feeling is we should address
all of these questions of collusion with
that same tool kit that's the right way
to do it and it doesn't involve
putting on a tinfoil hat so
are we being lied to a level
that is almost impossible to fathom and
that's one of the things
about the entire story of covid really
right and this starts i see the
lab leak hypothesis as
one leg of a three-legged stool of
places where
the very same people are trying to
control what it is we are allowed to
discuss
they are trying to shape a narrative
that a small amount of investigation
reveals is nonsense
and we have to
figure out how given that all of our
institutions seem to be participants in
this lie whether they know that they're
lying or not
we have to figure out how to make sense
of what we are facing
and plan for how we are going to escape
it with the minimal amount of damage
we're going to have to figure out how to
do that at the moment going around the
institutions the institutions are
simply an obstacle to uh civilization's
well-being and even knowing what's
taking place
i mean that's not exactly the answer
that i wanted
i'm gonna be honest with you why is it
what you know carry on and then i'll ask
you guys suggest um if you know
if if you wanted a happier answer i mean
you could have got a different guest for
one thing
but uh yeah go on
no so that being the case
why is it that big tech
all of these particular you know
institutions
have decided what is and what isn't
acceptable
at one point we i mean we could still
get kicked off but we could still have a
strike against our channel for this
particular interview
why is it all of a sudden that big tech
has deemed it acceptable that we can
have this conversation now whereas two
months down the line
it was deemed that it was unacceptable
two months ago
well i think the way to understand this
is
to keep multiple conversations
in mind simultaneously so it is now
perfectly acceptable anywhere you want
to have a
proper conversation about the lab leak
hypothesis
as you point out that was not true
several months back
and what changed was not the evidence
it is not that some piece of evidence
emerged that caused people to wake up
it was somehow a social decision and for
those of us
who have been demonized as conspiracy
theorists for
saying what most people now regard as
self-evident
um the the whole thing is rather
strange it's like we
against the odds managed to turn the
heat up high enough
on the garbage story that this obviously
came from nature
and anybody who thinks otherwise is
crazy we turned the heat on it
there were enough people with enough
different skill sets
to surface the evidence that eventually
that story just wasn't tenable and you
know
you remember the uh what is it colin rae
song that's my story and i'm sticking to
it
right where the dude comes home and his
wife asks him where he's been and he
said he fell asleep in the hammock in
the yard and she tells him
actually i threw the hammock in the
attic a week ago and he says well that's
my story and i'm sticking to it
right this is that right this
is for months there has been
uh clear nonsense being distributed as
if if
as if it were scientific consensus and
fact based on
uh scientific work and then eventually
the um the contradiction became so
glaring that whoever was trying to
maintain it decided to back off not all
the way it's not like they've come
clean it's not like they've admitted
that a laboratory leak is the most
likely explanation which it clearly is
um that what they've done is they've
decided to adjust
the story so that the um contradictions
are less obvious and then
to staunch the bleeding by establishing
a new false story which
we are now battling over but that is
taking place
we are now allowed to talk about the lab
league facebook says it's no longer
going to
uh take down posts on this topic well
thanks facebook
right um but we've got other topics that
have the exact
same profile right the exact same
profile where
those who talk about them uh are morally
defective they are
getting in the way of our you know
collective human campaign to fight off
kovid it's the same battle
the sensors are the same people and the
answer is if you
watched the lab leak thing happen
why are you not saying to yourself gee i
wonder if the people
who got the lab leak right uh
we're revealing something about what the
censorship is really
for right and whether or not
where i see that censorship still taking
place there might be something that i
desperately need to know about and there
is
bret do you think this is really the
level of sophistication of the thinking
about this
and this is a question that i really
want to talk to you about and we've been
talking for nearly now and we haven't
even got to the censorship part of it
properly but
the the the idea
that we live in a world now where
essentially four people in hoodies in
silicon valley
control the entirety of the mass
communication that occurs
and they are making decisions about what
we can and can't talk about
and it just seems inconceivable to me
that
youtube has a scientifically
sufficiently educated team to even make
this decision on the scientific basis
seems far more likely to me that the big
tech companies simply
get a note from the presidential
administration or from whoever
which says this is you know evil lying
propaganda that's undermining our
efforts to tackle a deadly pandemic
it must be suppressed and the hoodie
billionaire in silicon valley goes well
you know the the government's telling me
this so i don't have a clue
so i'm not a biologist i'm not a
epidemiologist i'm not
a virologist uh you know so i'm gonna do
what the government tell me because i
don't want to kill people
well but i mean think about what you're
saying i mean i i don't
i really do i don't think it's it's for
people in hoodies in fact one of the
strong possibilities here is that we
have
a uh i don't want to call it
artificially intelligent it's more like
artificially stupid
set of algorithms that are on autopilot
and that the folks in silicon valley who
feel that they are in control actually
would discover that they weren't if they
tried to change course right that this
is a process
you've got people staffing a process
that is out of control and yes it does
seem to be taking
direction from the cdc and the who
and we don't know uh who else but you
know in the u.s
to have the government telling
tech companies to silence individuals
is a pretty clear violation of the first
amendment
i would say the defense of censorship
has been these are private concerns and
they have a right
to have on their platform uh
who they want and to not have others now
that's a very shaky defense
but it falls apart completely if what
they are doing is taking directives from
a government
that is absolutely forbidden in our top
amendment
not to silence its citizens so
there's a big question here we don't
know how it works
but anybody who does even a little bit
of looking into this will discover
something absolutely ghastly and even if
you disagree on the content maybe you
think
natural origin is the most likely
explanation for the virus
maybe well i guess i gotta skip the
other topic so we don't uh put your
channel in jeopardy but
maybe you think i'm just wrong on the
evidence on these other things you still
have to ask yourself if i'm wrong
why is it so necessary to silence me
can't we just
have this out in public and find out
that i'm wrong because the evidence will
go against me
and what does that say about our society
bret that we silence people who disagree
with the narrative
it says that the
it says that something that has its own
incentives
has taken over and that we are
effectively passengers on a ship
headed to a destination we do not know
and bret i want to come back to the
point about these decisions not being
made scientifically because i come from
a family of scientists both my parents
were biochemists in the soviet union my
dad actually worked
on viruses and vaccines for the soviet
union at the time
and yet in our family conversations
about
alternative hypotheses about various
explanations for various events
were not only regular they were actively
encouraged
because i understood and i think my
parents understood who were very kind of
classically educated in science
that is the scientific method right it's
it's a discussion and a debate and a
series of
investigations and experiments about
what the truth may be
which produces a working theory that is
the best theory available until the next
one comes along
by a process of other people coming up
with other quote unquote conspiracy
theories about why that established
theory is now wrong
so how we got to a place where the more
science
advances and moves forward we're now
almost unable
to discuss the next potential hypothesis
that can explain something that is
as you say currently unexplained
there are two two important answers here
i think one
is we are confused as a a
um as a society about what science
is those of us who have dedicated our
life to it and who are very serious
about it in its detail
understand that science is a process it
is not a
collection of answers that we have
arrived at through that process
it is not a social system of people and
their beliefs
it is a process by which you find out
where
your perceptual biases have misled you
and you find out what is true in spite
of those biases that's the purpose of
science
and the only way it can work is in a
system that is open to entertaining all
possibilities
and then engaging in very serious
falsification
so to have this kind of mind-numbing
follow the science you know hashtag
mentality
where people think that following the
science is you know
re-broadcasting the bullet points in
the uh you know the press release is
to invert science this is
anti-scientific
that said people i think especially in
an emergency
are prone to just want to know what
they're supposed to do and
so anybody who wants to give false
certainty
about what the virus is how it transmits
what one should do to protect themselves
anybody who wants to tell the right kind
of story
has a huge and willing audience and
those people you know people want to
feel
for example all right we just got to get
ourselves to a vaccine
okay vaccine showed up earlier than
anybody was expecting that's kind of
great
maybe the answer is i've just simply got
to go get myself vaccinated i can relax
for the first time in more than a year
right i get that i understand why that's
comforting
such a person though does not want to
hear the
nuances they don't want to hear what we
don't know about the implication of
those
vaccines right they don't want to hear
about the fact that you have
multiple novel phenomena being deployed
at once in a process
that has been shortened in order to
bring it to the public
more quickly and that that means we know
even less than we would know ordinarily
right they don't want to know these
things because frankly
it makes it hard to sleep um so you know
lots of people are lying to themselves
because what they want is a comforting
story and they'd like to just cross
their fingers and hope it's right
and the problem is those of us who don't
sleep
very well until we've actually looked
into these things are not comforted by
the story and we are not comforted by
the official powers that be handing down
what's absolute nonsense right this has
been clear from the beginning
heather and i have been shouting for
much more than a year about the fact
that this virus does not appear to
transmit outdoors
that it does appear that people who have
more vitamin d
are better off than people who have less
vitamin d that you should go outdoors
you should not wear a mask except in
maybe very unusual circumstances
outdoors
and that for the powers that be to tell
us
effectively you need a mask at all times
because the entire world is suddenly
dangerous is wrong more than 99
of the world is not dangerous because
it's not inside a building or a car or
an airplane
right all of that space is safe and for
the last year and a half we should have
been
using that fact to take a break from
covid and go talk about what's really
going on
outside in comparative safety right but
we haven't been doing it
because something is very interested in
us listening to its dictates about what
we should do and that is a very alarming
fact
do you think the governments have been
using this as a power grab
in a very cynical sense the problem
is so
we have a composite of two things
that are almost certain both to be
present on the one hand
there is collusion behind the scenes
of people who have objectives that we
don't know about right there are
meetings in which people decide what to
do and the reasons that they decide what
we should do
are not necessarily about our well-being
you know that bro
we also have no i'm serious how do you
know that those meetings are happening
well for one thing you can detect the
way
that the lab leak hypothesis suddenly
became
mainstream involved
a series of acknowledgments over the
course of
days in other words some email chain
or zoom call or meeting
resulted in a conclusion which is okay
that story is not going to work the news
story is going to look like this
and so the people who were in on it
started repositioning themselves and
in the course of two weeks everything
was different and you had
a whole new set of people championing
the lab leak hypothesis who had been mum
or had been demonizing it up until right
before and so the point is you can
detect
that something unnatural has caused a
shift in the narrative and there are
many
such things but anyway my point about
this is
you have collusion and you have
emergence
right there's also a certain organic
phenomenon that happens
the who and the cdc are not scientific
organizations
they're about public health and public
health involves
stories that are simple enough to get
people to do
what we need them to do right and the
problem is that's in conflict with
knowing what's actually happening
and it's especially dangerous to allow
the thing that licenses it
licenses itself to lie in order to get
the public to do what it needs to do
to allow those lies to start interfering
with scientific inquiry is especially
dangerous
it's like you know putting on blinders
before you run down the stairs
so you've got emergence right natural
processes that are
set in motion for one reason and then
evolve into something else
and you've got collusion people actually
having meetings and deciding to shut
down some line of inquiry or whatever
we never know the admixture right so
it could be that this is 99
emergence and one percent collusion or
it could be reversed or it could be
somewhere in the middle and
if you're going to think about these
issues it's very important i believe
to enter into them with the sense of in
a complex story like this
both things are going to be there and
the question is what's the ratio
right is this mostly a story of
collusion or is this mostly a story of
emergence or is it
divided between them in some you know
haphazard fashion
the thing that i find you know we talk
about this
the thing that i find very worrying is
that when i speak to most people
they want an end to this they want this
to end they want to return to normal
i don't think we're ever going to return
to normal as it was
i think this is for the long term do you
share my pessimism
well it's two questions really i said
back
in oh probably it would have been
february of 2020
we're never going back to normal i don't
think we're ever going back to normal
doesn't mean i don't think we could
drive covet extinct in fact what i have
come to understand
recently is that probably we could have
driven covid
extinct months ago and that we are not
doing it for reasons
that are mysterious
right you would imagine that everybody
given the opportunity to drive covet to
extinction
would be interested in doing that and
that were
that were there a question about whether
that was really possible
and i believe honest brokers who have
looked at all the information reasonable
people could disagree over whether or
not it is possible to drive covid
to extinction with the tools we
presently have in short order
but if you even think that that's
possible
and the tools are the right ones to
bring to bear whether or not we're stuck
with covid
then you should certainly bring them to
bear and our failure to do that
is utterly alarming
i really cannot emphasize enough how
strange our behavior
is in light of the tools at our disposal
and bret i take it that if i ask you
what those tools are you're going to
give me an answer that will get us
banned from youtube is that correct
well how about we i mean you know
personally
my feeling is um
you know how can i say this
it'd be great it'd be great if you guys
just
grew a pair it doesn't have to be
perfect we're getting called out live on
ass
one between you is enough i think right
and the fact is look i'm probably gonna
lose my channel over this but
from what i've seen if it takes losing
my channel in order to make the point
about what we're doing wrong
then so be it even though my channel is
the bulk of my family's income
so yeah i understand that not
everybody's in that position
no brad i'll tell you what the
difficulty is for us and i actually
think it's important for us to discuss
this the difficulty for us
is that we are not scientists and so the
the stuff that
and the reason we wanted to have this
conversation with you is we know you
we've met you like we both consider your
friend and we trust that you wouldn't be
doing what you're doing if there wasn't
a good reason for it but nonetheless
we don't have the ability to
independently verify
the stuff that you're talking about so
we're delighted that you've joined us
and
you know you're right to call us out to
some extent i don't want to be sitting
here going
bro you can't talk about this well you
can i don't no no
i don't i don't even i don't even i know
you don't i know
the concern for us is that we are not
able to independently verify
it so we want to bring the conversation
to people's attention
right and we want to make people aware
that you've talked about some of this
other stuff
elsewhere and they're welcome to seek it
out okay so i'm not going to put you
guys
in danger i understand what you're
protecting i agree with you that my
responsibility here is far
greater than yours because i am in a
position to look at
the the evidence and evaluate it with
at least some of the right tools and i'm
in contact with people who have the
other tools and
the picture is quite clear to me in a
way i wouldn't expect it to be clear to
you
but i would point out that there are two
questions on the table
okay there are series of topics that are
scientific and technical in nature
and there's the censorship issue which
is not and the point is the technical
ones
require the censorship one to be solved
and
so my concern is
that a legitimate fear that you're not
in a position to evaluate the scientific
questions is going to result in too much
timidity on
too many channels with respect to the
censorship censorship issue
which is clearly out of control right
for them to come after me
when i've had uh you know clinicians
on who are um who have
saved many people from covid people who
have actually
innovated the current standard of care
people who
are important players in the story of
how we have medically addressed
covet are saying there's something that
we're not doing and there's no good
reason for it i've had them on my
channel
right so anyway the the question
is is there perhaps some way
you know you you mentioned uh that we
could refer
um to some of these forbidden topics as
voldemort the problem with that is that
i think
you know and it's i i you know i'm a
scientist i'm not a literature guy
but in in reading the harry potter
series my
feeling was that voldemort
is pretty unambiguously bad you know
you have to be pretty postmodern to not
see him as sort of a negative character
so my sense is if we use that euphemism
that it gives the wrong impression about
the things that we are not saying and so
i was going to suggest that maybe
we could do something uh we could refer
to the things that we can't talk about
in uh a more sympathetic and appealing
way
like you know could we refer to the
central tool that we are
not using in the fight against kovid as
jody foster in the movie contact or
something like that
could we refer to some of the other
tools as maybe
um sigourney weaver in alien
and for people who don't swing that way
could we refer to
to the other tools that we're not using
as uh
matt damon in the born under a bad sign
is there some way that we could make
these things
approachable so that we could discuss
them i think the best thing to do is
maybe
for you before we go to the q and a's
for you to tell people
who you've had the conversations with
and they can go and find that
information
sure so the conversations that i think
are most
salient are i had a conversation that
has now been removed
by youtube with pierre corey pierre
corey
of the frontline covid19 critical care
alliance which are a group of doctors
that got together when covid began
in order to figure out how you treat
these patients who had this brand new
disease
and they worked very hard to figure out
what worked what didn't work they
followed the evidence
and they have settled on
some alarmingly good treatments that
are now being hidden for reasons that
are unfortunately becoming
quite apparent right there are financial
reasons
that we are not using our best tools are
there other reasons i don't know but the
financial ones are clear enough they can
be demonstrated
pretty easily so i had pierre on um
and it was a a great conversation
youtube removed it
i should point out they also and i think
as
shocking as it is that they re removed a
conversation
between a biologist and a doctor about a
pandemic and its uh potential treatment
they also removed pierre cory's
congressional testimony he testified in
front of the senate on the very same
topic and
youtube removed what
this is absolutely factual he testified
on this topic
and youtube removed it okay just
think about that this is insane this is
a
highly decorated doctor this is somebody
who saves
lives for a living this is an icu doc
right he goes to
we go and do whatever we do on on
youtube
he goes to work and saves people and he
testified to congress
and it was extremely popular and it was
widely circulating
and youtube took it down now my claim is
even if he had been a crank
a crank testifying in front of congress
is something the public needs to be able
to see
there is no explanation for why youtube
would deem itself in a position
to remove such a thing um and i can tell
you i've looked at the evidence
and the evidence is high quality there
are meta analyses that have been done
that make it clear that even if you have
complaints about the size of the various
studies when you compile the evidence
the signal is unambiguous
and so anyway that's one of the
conversations the other conversation
was one i had more recently with steve
kirsch
steve kirsch is the inventor of the
optical
mouse and he has done research
on the impacts of the
covid vaccines he is fully vaccinated he
has done research on the impact the
medical impact of the
covet 19 vaccines and in that
conversation
we were with robert malone who is
literally the inventor
of the mrna vaccine
technology that is at the core of most
of these vaccines
so we had a conversation a three-way
conversation it is still up
about the nature of these vaccines and
uh
i only wish i could give you a summary
of it but people should look
for for that conversation on
the darkhorse podcast channel if they
want to see the conversation
that youtube removed between pierre cory
and me
the fl c that's the front line critical
covid critical care alliance website
has the podcast still up on bitshoot
and it is also available as audio
on all of the usual podcast apps
and so one thing i would say if you're
interested in the censorship
censorship issue then whether or not
you are inclined to entertain
these descriptions of heterodox thinking
surrounding vaccination
and other covid treatments you should
certainly
take the following to heart if the
sensors are going to lose
their censorship has to fail when
somebody censors
something that appears to be important
whether it's congressional testimony of
a frontline coveted doctor
whether it's an evolutionary biologist
talking to the inventor
of a vaccine technology when something
is censored
you should probably take extra interest
in it
right what is it i am not supposed to
hear and you may find
that the sensors are right that certain
content isn't any good now i wouldn't
advise that they censor it
but it may be that what you find when
you scratch the surface is yes there's
something compromised about this
discussion it is not informative or you
may find that it's
very informative and that some force
does not want you to know the content
because it has interests that run in
some other direction and i would just
invite people
to look at these conversations and judge
for themselves
and i occurs to me that our lack of a
pair as you
gently put a breath is also a bit of a
test case because we have deliberately
stayed away from the one thing
your video with pierre was banned for uh
and so
it would be interesting whether they
feel the need to censor
a reference to a conversation that's now
been deleted
and to see how far they're willing to go
uh in that process
well my sense uh having looked at this
is that um you're probably
safe from youtube's hammer uh
if you're speaking obliquely and not
making
claims but simply referring to the fact
that claims have been made somewhere
else and inviting people
uh to look at those things i of course
don't know
um but the the important thing
is that when somebody makes a decision
like this
the important thing is that it actually
amplifies
rather than tamps down the investigation
into the question
right the fact that something is being
censored shouldn't convince you that
it's true
but the fact that something is being
censored should convince you
that somebody doesn't want you to hear
this and then you can quickly check and
figure out whether they're acting in
your interest
and in this case i believe it is utterly
unambiguous they are acting in someone
else's interest
and on that rather upbeat note we
are going to cut to a commercial break
and we'll be back in around
three to four minutes and we'll be
facing
your questions to brett so see you in
three to four minutes guys
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be council culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns of rock
solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off with the initial purchase sign up
for their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course
incredible interviews hilarious live
streams
hard-hitting satire plus my handsome
jawline
whatever takes away from your hairline
but if you do love trigonometry
and you want to support us there's only
one place to do that
and that's on locals yes locals is a
brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive
to our show and other problematic
creators
the great thing about locals is that
it's a community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people
share thoughts memes and discuss the
show you can enjoy it for free
but it also gives you the option of
supporting us for
as little as seven dollars a month and
if you want to give more
you can we have incredible rewards for
our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group course and one on two chats with
me and kcat
get in join our community by hitting the
link
in the description and the pin comment
below see you there guys
do you want to promote your business to
an intelligent audience
who don't need to know your pronouns to
buy your product
here at trigonometry we have over 250
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and we frequently get
over 3 million views a month that's a
lot of new customers
for your business we speak with some of
the biggest guests from the worlds of
politics
economics journalism arts and
entertainment
all of them have spent at least one
month in the gulag
so you don't have to and we'll match
your product to the perfect guest for
you
american sponsors will be matched with
american guests and so on
that way you know your advert has the
best possible chance
of getting to the right people or as we
call them the wrong people
advertise with us and we'll get your
business cancelled or your money back
contact us by email at marketing
triggerpod.co.uk and we'll make
your nightmares come true
all right hello everybody and welcome
back anton let's get
back in here so we can ask the questions
brett uh questions are flowing in
already
uh iron shirt says how likely is it that
the zoonotic origin would produce a
virus that didn't know how to infect
people out of doors
well this is a great question i've made
this point several places that there's
something conspicuous
about it not transmitting at all
outdoors it seems or almost never
and there are really two interpretations
i think it is highly likely that that is
the result that this virus
adapted to a laboratory environment
which is obviously
the sort of indoor of indoors and
that that is a signature of something
the question
is as a bat virus how would it have
normally transmitted
and my guess is that in general the the
bats in question these
uh these horseshoe bats are forest
dwelling
bats that would not be collected in
large numbers
in the foraging environment
so the place where the virus would have
been most likely to transmit between
them
would have been inside a roost like a
cave
is a cave more like an indoor
environment or an outdoor environment
it's not entirely clear but i would say
my guess is when this is all over and we
know the answer
it will probably turn out that the
inability of the virus to transmit
itself
almost ever in the outdoor environment
has something to do with laboratory
origin
but it is possible um that it is the
result of
the nature of the bat roasting
environment where the virus would
transmit
under normally just as a follow-up from
me brett do we have any
scientific idea of why the virus is so
ineffective as tr
transmitting itself outside yeah this is
a beautiful question
the answer is it's going to be two
things
right we know that it is highly
sensitive to uv light
uv light destroys it but if it were just
uv light then it would be transmissible
at night
outdoors and not during the day and
that's not what we see
so the other factor is what i would call
effective volume this virus is very
sensitive because of the way it
transmits by effectively
saturating the air with particles that
float some of them for a very long time
the uh the virus is very sensitive to
how much air there is that is to say how
long it takes to saturate
how much flow there is and therefore how
quickly it is distributed
and um basically things like uh
aridity so my point would be if you're
in a room
if you're in a car with an uber driver
who has covet
that's a very tiny effective volume and
it will saturate very quickly
and the likelihood that you will get it
in spite of the fact that you're wearing
a mask is quite high
right if you open the windows of that
car it's effective
volume jumps if it's standing at a stop
light it jumps a lot if it's moving down
the highway it jumps astronomically
so the effective volume is the question
and basically effective volume
goes to infinity as you go outside so it
is these two things that seem to be
working
in tandem that make the virus so
difficult to transmit in an outdoor
environment
that's a great answer thank you very
much brett and we have a wonderful
question from james hogg
he said uh brett do you think science's
actions were affected by the politics of
covet
19. these are not trump supporters and
the league
theory became trump's has it affected
our object
our objectivity and how do we learn from
this it's a good question
there's clearly something
about you know i hate to use these terms
and it's in fact
gotten me in trouble before but there is
something about trump derangement
syndrome
that actually turns out not just to be
you know a funny punchline
trump derangement syndrome has made it
impossible for us to think
analytically that is to say i am stunned
by
the degree to which journalists have
settled on the story
that they could not possibly have been
expected to see
through the natural origin story because
trump had said some things that
suggested he thought the origin wasn't
natural
in what universe do you give anyone the
power
to get you not to look into something by
them embracing it
right if you hand your enemy that
capacity the ability to dissuade you
from investigating something
by simply embracing it they own you so
i don't know what it is that happened to
people i don't you know
if trump lied every time he opened his
mouth
that would not mean that whatever came
out of his mouth was the opposite of
true it would mean there was no
information in it
right that's the answer if you decide
that trump is simply
a a non-source of information because
everything is a lie
you don't embrace the opposite of what
he thinks
you just take it as non-information and
you move on from there and if people had
done
that they would have found that the lab
leak hypothesis was the most probable
from very early in 2020
and brit doesn't that also mean that you
we you can't trust the mainstream media
in that case
because if they're not being objective
about what trump is saying
then ultimately what are they not being
objective about
and this is this is really my point is
this i think is the best chance
we're ever going to get to see this
because you don't usually win these
battles
we have in a sense a very limited sense
won the battle
on the lively hypothesis we have taken
it from
being demonized and stigmatized as a tin
foil hat conspiracy theory
and gotten it to the mainstream so that
we are actually now at least beginning
to have a conversation about what the
evidence really does suggest
at the same time we have not jumped that
gap with several other stories
related to covid and that gives us the
opportunity to just simply take
what we learned or should have learned
in the lab leak case
and apply it to these other stories and
what that says is
wow the sources that you would just love
to trust cannot be trusted you have to
look past them you have to figure out
who is having conversations
that actually make analytical sense
because the other thing is just like
a distribution point for propaganda
right we got propagandized on lab league
the people who told us for sure that we
were crazy to worry about it coming from
a lab behind the scenes looked at it
and said to each other over email you
know what this looks like it came from a
lap
right they're telling you something you
shouldn't have to wait for the emails to
come spilling out
in order to to get the sense that you
need to look deeper
and bret then the the ultimate question
for for people is
if i can't trust the mainstream media to
be objective
if i can't trust these traditional
people who i get my information from
then who can i trust well
yeah and you know you you can't trust
anybody
at the level of just tell me what to
think that's that's the bitter pill
here right you never could what you can
do is you can trust people to navigate
the issue
as an honest broker and to show their
work right that's the most you can hope
for
and when you get people who show their
work
and attempt to navigate the issue
honestly
then you can check their track record
over time right
still doesn't mean that they're right
but it's a process that allows you to
figure out
you know on balance where should you put
your trust and where shouldn't you
and you know the thing is it would be
wonderful
if we had things like newspapers that
accumulated people who were trustworthy
to sort these things out for us
so that we could go to them and find out
you know what somebody with resources
would discover if they
went down some rabbit hole unfortunately
somehow
in 2021 there are no such papers
that's an amazing fact there are no such
universities
how is that possible none of the places
that you would like to go to just figure
out
what smart people who are in a good
position to see the evidence
conclude there's no institution that can
do that job at this moment
and really that's the biggest emergency
we have
bret matt is asking a question that
actually i care about as well and i
think is an important question to ask
one of the narratives here in the uk i
don't know
what the situation is in america is that
everyone
must take the vaccine because even if
you as an individual
uh let's say a child or a young healthy
person who
who seems to have a lot less to fear
from from this virus
by not being vaccinated you're creating
the environment which is likely to cause
more variance to come about
um wouldn't and he says wouldn't a
vaccinated environment produce
greater selection and more mutation and
by the way let me add a question on my
own is actually mutation
bad because one of the narratives we had
at the beginning of this virus emerging
was that
we needed to mutate more and more so
that it can become less lethal
well the question of it evolving to
become less lethal
effectively assumes a natural origin and
once you discover that this is not a
natural origin the natural rules don't
apply
so how it will evolve is an open
question uh so i would say yes
for the moment variants are bad because
to the extent that people who have had
covet or have had the vaccine
are immune to something it's to the
initial variant and that will decay over
time
and i think one of the vulnerabilities
of these vaccines even if these vaccines
worked exactly as we had hoped which
they do not but
if the vaccines worked exactly as we had
hoped then
they are still very narrowly focused on
the spike protein
and that means that that is an intense
evolutionary
pressure for the spike protein to evolve
so as to become invisible to the immune
system so that's a hazard here
and i would say variants are bad
as for the question about shouldn't we
vaccinate people
who are young and therefore not very
vulnerable to covid i find this
the most maddening feature of this
entire
situation young people do not need to be
vaccinated to protect them
i understand the argument that we want
to have as many people
immune as possible to protect others but
what society
what society liquidates the health of
young people
in order to preserve the health of old
people
right now if the vaccines were in fact
safe that would be a different question
right if there were no cost that we
could detect in young people
of having the vaccines then we could
raise the question of whether or not
the risk that there was something we
didn't know downstream
was worth exposing them to in order to
protect
older infirm people that's not the case
we have very strong signals now we have
unexplained deaths in the thousands
maybe the tens of thousands even just
here in the us
we have clotting disorders we have heart
failures
we've got strokes these things
one cannot establish on the basis of a
very noisy system of reporting exactly
where they are from
but the point is anybody should be able
to look at what is taking place and know
that we don't know enough about the
consequences of vaccinating people with
these
vaccines to expose children to it it
makes no
sense right and if you say to yourself
well i differ
you know covet is serious enough and you
know human life is precious no matter
what age it is and we should we should
you know the risk of the vaccines is
small compared to the risk of covid
if that's what you think then you got to
ask yourself this question
why on earth are we vaccinating people
who had
coveted they will get the very same
immunity there's no evidence their
immunity gets better for vaccinating
them
we are exposing those people to the
risks of these vaccines
for no benefit it doesn't make anybody
else immune it doesn't get us any closer
to herd immunity
so there is something in the environment
that is hell bent on vaccinating people
whether or not it makes sense to do so
and the proof of that
is in the fact that we are vaccinating
people who have already had covet and
therefore
are already effectively vaccinated
i mean yeah just ask the next question
the youtube channel comedy podcast
yeah i love you just crack on me oh yeah
i
uh yeah this is what i used to call in
teaching a sweaty back moment
anyway yeah this is from mb uh
and he says uh brett did your
experiences at evergreen
help prime your skepticism on current
issues or have you been aware of
underlying issues with public health
well i mean let's put it this way um
my development as a kid and as a young
adult
set me in motion to look behind the
scenes and what
happens when you do that is you do
discover that there's an awful lot of
cover story and an awful lot of
ugly process behind the
the veil now on the public health front
i would say
the most important developmental
experience was my experience as a
graduate student
when i started looking into the
evolution
of telomeres senescence and cancer
and what i found was that there is a
flaw
in our model mice
that results in them being terrifically
prone to cancer and terrifically
resistant
to toxins and
that was alarming to me because we used
those animals in
drug safety testing and so i tried to
raise the alarm
and the bell wouldn't ring i was
unable to call the attention of
the professional public to this giant
hazard that our mice
were predisposed to tell us that toxic
drugs were safe
and that this would explain things like
the vioxx
phenomenon the seldane phenomenon
fenfen gleevec a whole range of drugs
have shown themselves to be very
dangerous when we thought they were
comparatively safe and all of this is
easily explained
by the fact that the mice that we use to
detect toxicity are actually prone
to resist it but in any case once you've
seen
the system refuse to engage such a
hazard
um it wakes you up and one
loses their naivete rather quickly
bret first of all uh axana has messaged
in uh with a with a paypal just saying
how much he appreciates everything
you're doing and thanking you for it
uh but also we had a lot of questions
about the role of the world health
organization
in all of this uh so uh
what do you make of because some of the
stuff that has come out
from that particular institution over
the last year and a bit
has just been mind-boggling starting
from no
human to human transmission all the way
through to all sorts of other stuff
uh that at one point they were saying
lockdowns are essential and i think at
another point they were saying
lockdowns are a temporary measure that
shouldn't be used to
you know just completely contradictory
stuff over a long period of time
what do you make of the role of the
health world world health organization
and all of this
and how should we uh see that
institution
in the light of everything that's been
happening um
i would say the central issue of our day
is capture
and unfortunately capture has become
synonymous with a narrow version called
regulatory capture
so regulatory capture involves a
corporation
or an industry gaining control over the
regulators that are supposed to dictate
the limits of what it can do
but that is a small version of something
that has a much larger form and i would
say the signal is very strong
that things like the who the cdc
the major tech platforms the
universities
the journals the newspapers these things
have been
captured and their capture renders them
unreliable that's a very frightening
fact to have all of those things
captured and the way in which they were
captured
i think is not understood by anyone i
think there are many different
mechanisms afoot and
frankly we may we may be up against
evolution itself
it may be that capture evolves and has
taken over each of these things in
course
and uh that has resulted in an
environment
in which they're all untrustworthy but
yeah i've looked at the who
over the course of the coveted pandemic
and i am constantly shocked by
how it distributes utter nonsense as if
it were
a fact beyond criticism
um and anybody who looks at the series
of pronouncements that have come out of
the who can tell something's wrong
absolutely i actually want to pick up on
something you said then we alluded to
before the q a but i want to get into
and maybe push back
on something that you're talking about
because
uh you'll remember in our conversation
with jordan heather
only last week we talked about the fact
that technological
change has been so rapid many of the
societal shifts that we now see and many
of the other problems that we're now
experiencing seem to be
a product primarily of that more than
anything else
do you not think that given the fact
that basically in the last 10
15 years we've invented an uber mega
nuclear printing press
which is what social media big tech
really is
that there is some some responsibility
on these institutions
to to to to acknowledge
the huge power that they've given to
ordinary people who some of whom like
you
are acting in good faith but there's
also others you know we had the example
of
david ike making comments about the link
between covert and 5g
and then bang the next day people are
burning [ __ ] down five gmas
that's that's a terrible thing to be
happening in my opinion so
look i'm putting this as a as a sort of
devil's advocate argument but i do think
it needs to be put
do you not think there has to be some
regulation of what is published in
particularly in the heightened situation
like this
you know the analogy might be made with
a wartime in wartime broadcasting
wartime publication etc
where there is some restriction in for
the greater good if you like
with very few exceptions i would say no
and the reason is not that i don't
understand the hazard you're pointing to
or i don't think it's serious i think
it's
very serious but i think this is a
simple question
of net effect right unfortunately
the novelty of the tech platforms and
the way that they have created
a new pattern of collective cognition
that is a very frightening and dangerous
fact
we are now linked together in not only a
global industrial system but a global
proto mind of some kind
i'm not saying that's safe what i am
saying
is that a mind in which something has
the power to regulate
what can be considered by whom and in
what way
that mind is much more dangerous than
one in which anything can be considered
and ultimately one hopes that the truth
has
power over the nonsense right the danger
of creating the limitation is
greater than the danger of the
admittedly dangerous fictions that will
circulate in that environment
we have to hope that that's true because
the other route
involves a very predictable collapse
of sense making that in the context of
our
industrial capacity i think would
certainly be fatal
in short order what are you talking
about brett
i'm talking about the ability to prevent
um processes from
happening right we have many different
uh existential threats that have not yet
grown
to a scale of being existential
independently
but they are linked together in a way
that puts us in
great jeopardy the problem is the
profits to be made in each of these
realms from
generating these things is sufficient
that there is an evolutionary pressure
for those who want to engage in these
processes because it enriches them to do
so
they have a pressure to capture the
entities that might raise the alarm
about the hazard of what they're doing
right we have to be able to raise the
hazard but if every industry
is able to frustrate discussion of the
danger that flows out of the new process
it has just invented
then one of those processes is going to
get us soon and we've seen
how many of these things now right we've
seen the financial collapse of 2008
we've seen the deepwater horizon
blow out we've seen the fukushima triple
meltdown
uh we've seen the elizo canyon leak
we've seen
uh the kovid 19 which it appears
probably came from the lab in wuhan
all of these things have the same
signature some
industry is doing something that the
public only finds out about
once the accident has happened right now
so far all of these things including
covet 19 have been much better than they
might have been
one of these days we're going to get
unlucky and the magnitude of the
accident is going to be so great there
won't be any recovering so
it is of the utmost importance
that humanity figures out how to have
the discussions about which processes
are safe enough for us to engage in
what is the way in which we will engage
in them so that when something goes
wrong we can reverse course
we have to have that conversation and
it's never going to happen if there's a
mechanism there that is allowed to
regulate what we can talk about and it
is available to be captured by those
with a financial incentive to do so
what you're saying if i can if i can
rephrase it is we essentially now have
an established system of
anti-transparency
we have a system of anti-transparency
where
any conversation there's a price point
for shutting down a conversation and if
you just go
industry by industry right each of the
industries that is engaged in some
process with the potential
for a catastrophe where the costs will
be borne by humanity
not by the corporation in each of those
cases there is an incentive to use the
levers that may have been erected nobly
to prevent dangerous conversations to
prevent people from burning down 5g
towers or whatever it is
there's going to be a incentive to
capture those mechanisms and make sure
that they do not talk about the hazards
and the public's interest
we've seen it too many times already and
we have to get away from
the idea that we are going to solve the
problem by increasing the quality of
speech by purging the stuff that we all
agree is wrong
you can't do that because the problem
nobody on earth has ever figured out how
you
sort the vast array
of quackery
and fringe nonsense from the heterodoxy
that travels in the same layer every
great idea starts as a minority of one
and the problem is if you had a magic
formula for
spotting which idea over in the fringe
layer was actually the next great idea
and so you could throw out all of the
nonsense ideas that are over there
you'd be king right but it can't be done
you can't there's no mechanism for
sorting the really important heterodoxy
that nobody
believes yet but we'll all believe down
the road from the nonsense that nobody
reasonable is ever going to believe
because it really is garbage right you
have to wait for heterodoxy to either
demonstrate its power or go away
and so we can't improve the quality of
the conversation unless what you want to
do
is say well we've got enough progress
already so heterodoxy is done
and if you do that we're finished as a
species we have to we we can't stay here
our processes are not sustainable
we have to get out of this by innovating
our way to a sustainable
existence on planet earth so you can't
freeze progress here and if you can't
freeze progress here
you can't shut down heterodoxy by
shutting down every idea that isn't you
know certified by the cdc
bret isn't this a symptom of late stage
capitalism in which you have
four companies that have a stranglehold
on the market
and therefore because they have no
competitors they can do pretty much as
they please
no not really because what it is
you know what we call late stage
capitalism and of course i'm not
entirely sure what we mean by that but
it's effectively a instantiation of a
natural process
right it's an evolutionary environment
in which there are niches
and we discover them with the evolution
of strategies
and so those corporations
as angry as i am at them for attempting
for the hubris involved in thinking that
they can regulate the conversation into
a better place
they are responding to evolutionary
pressures they are like
a liquid filling a volume
right they are creatures filling a niche
and if we want better corporations if we
want them to stand
down and stop attempting to regulate
discussion
we need to create the environment where
the niches are such that that
process doesn't evolve it'll happen each
and every time
so late stage capitalism is another way
of saying
you know a political and economic
version of
nature's experiment and yeah it's red in
tooth and claw
and if we don't want it to be we have to
create an environment where
something better evolves
fantastic did you have a question uh or
do you want me to shall i go to another
you go to another question it's a
question from jay who's one of our
regular viewers he says brett can you
please comment on doctor is a keys i
think it's dr key's article in the wall
street journal
he talked about the insertion of a
double cgg sequence found in covert 19
in the exact same place as the furan
cleavage site
is as well it's a two telltale signs of
artificial manipulation in the lab
according to dr kia are you are you
familiar with this i think that was my
question right to be honest
um i am familiar what's a cgg mate
my it's i don't want to steal brett's
thunder bret you carry on please mate
i think it is what i want people to do
in this case is to actually
simplify the genomic questions they are
tremendously
complex to some of us they are very
interesting but
in effect when ralph barrick came out in
science magazine
as co-author on an article
saying that the lab leak hypothesis
needed to be investigated
here you have the world's unambiguous
leader the person who has innovated
more of the techniques in question a
person who knows more
about what is possible and what it would
look like than anyone else on earth
telling you i have looked at this genome
i've seen everything you've seen
up to the point this paper is published
there's nothing in the sequence that is
incompatible with the idea
of a laboratory origin and in fact a
laboratory origin is likely enough that
it must be investigated right
you couldn't ask for a clearer signal
that what is in the genome
is at the very least consistent with
laboratory origin and taken in
conjunction
with the emails that we've now seen
exchanged by cr christian anderson
and anthony fauci this is
uh it is quite clear many have looked at
this and they have
seen the signature of a laboratory
origin
that there are different techniques
involved we're talking about
in some cases like the fern cleavage
site potentially in fact very likely to
be
an insert that was placed in the genome
and then
we see evidence of serial passage so
i don't want to engage the argument
specifically but i don't think there's
any reason for people to be focused on
it because what we have
finally after a year and a half of
fighting over this
is a at least clear acknowledgement that
what is in that genome is consistent
with laboratory origin
and that those who know the most believe
we have to look in that direction
bret well we've got one more question
another couple of minutes brett uh and
this is probably a good one to finish on
actually because casey says
are there reliable people at entities
that are archiving your dark host videos
somewhere so youtube
uh isn't the only place that they can be
found and uh
so that there's a place to find them if
they're not on youtube anymore
um yes we certainly have them all and we
are going to make sure that they are
available but i want
the public who is interested in this to
think very carefully there is a
huge chorus of people that have been uh
signaling at me and saying you know
change platforms go somewhere else where
they can't do this to you and the
problem is
the audience is on youtube and the fact
that i might be able to solve a problem
for my channel
the fact that i might be able to solve a
problem for my family and our income
stream
by taking the content and putting it
somewhere else or the fact that i might
be able to solve a problem
for an interested person who wants to
know where they can go find it
is not the real question the question is
how can the material live in some place
where it reaches
enough people to wake them and to change
what's going on because what's going on
is killing people right that's a very
serious claim i'm aware of how serious
it is but it effectively leaves me
with very little choice i have to do
what i'm doing
the personal costs are terrible but
i don't i just don't see that there is
morally any room
not to point out what it is i'm seeing
and help people try to understand it
that makes a lot of sense bret thank you
so much for coming on the show
if uh where is the best place to follow
i mean we've
addressed it but follow you on twitter
etc etc
yeah follow me on twitter at brett
weinstein
check out the dark horse podcast which
for the moment at least
is still on youtube it is still
available on
all of the major podcast apps
that's apple spotify all of those
you can come to my patreon and support
my
work we are generating
a way that people who prefer to pay in
cryptocurrency can do that
um maybe that's about it
uh brett thank you so much i should just
say before we let you go that uh there's
a tremendous
number of people who are sending
messages thanking you for everything
you're doing
and we really appreciate coming on i
know that uh you would have wanted to
have
a more frank conversation about this uh
and i feel very guilty i feel like i'm a
disappointing son to a very good dad
no no no no can i say i feel a little
bad about what i said
and that had this conversation taken
place
in a room full of good-natured people
that would have gotten a tremendous
laugh and the attention over uh
it would have been dissipated
immediately and anyway please don't take
it personally
no you're very kind and look uh i i
would love to live in the world
that we don't have to to do things this
way and i i'm
i feel like uh with people like you in
the world
uh that will eventually happen so please
keep fighting the good fight and we'll
do our best as well
to you guys as well all right be well
thanks brett and thanks everybody for
watching take care
and thank you very much for watching
guys and if you
want to follow us please do all our
shows
and live streams go out 7pm uk
time tuesday thursday friday
saturday and sunday and wednesday for
our episodes
take care see you soon we hope you've
enjoyed this
incredible interview remember to
subscribe and hit the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry
is important support us by joining our
locals community
using the link below